[Music]
Ronda santis and Gavin Newsome throwing
down in the Epic Red versus Blue State
debate on Hannity the two high-profile
Governors talking trash for months and
finally getting the chance to hammer
each other's record face to face they
tax too much they regulate too much they
have a political agenda it's not a good
climate for business they've lost a lot
of companies California dominates size
of 21 State populations combin it's the
fifth largest economy in the world he
had the kids locked out of school
because of the teachers union that is
having a generational impact the last
guy you want to talk to on the
immigration lying to migrants promising
them jobs and housing sending them to an
island Martha's Vineyard well this is an
app where they plot the human feces that
are found on the Streets of San
Francisco God the two also taking some
vicious personal shots at each other I
can handle it I'm used to bully you're
nothing but a bully understand that
he'll tell a blizzard of lies to be able
to try to MK the failures you're
trolling folks and trying to find
migrants to play political games try to
get some news intention so you can out
Trump trump and by the way how's that
going for you Ron you're down 41 points
in your own home state he's just
throwing stuff out to see what sticks
against the wall this is a slick
slippery politician I will take Joe
Biden at a 100 versus Ronda santis any
day of the week at any age Des STIs and
knew some trading Jabs over their future
political Ambitions when are you going
to drop out and at least give Nikki
Haley a shot to take down Donald Trump
in this nomination she laid you
out you will not admit it why that
you're running hold on I don't know how
many times I can say just making this
stuff up about a shadow campaign what
Biden and Harris and Nome want to do is
take the California model and do that
nationally there's one thing in closing
that we have in common is neither of us
will be the nominee for our party in
2024 judge Janine Piro you've been
chopping at the bit all day wanting to
get this off your chest what's going on
can I tell you something he is a
mean-spirited Petty guy and I got
no no obviously greasy Gavin okay that's
my new name for him you know the thing
that he the thing that I found most
offensive was one that really didn't
have a lot to do with substance it's
when he interrupted uh Ron when he was
talking about Biden and the teachers
union and uh kamla Harris and he
interrupted I don't know if we have that
sound guys where he says by the way it's
not kamla Harris shame on you it's kamla
it's kamla it's Madam vice president to
you stop insulting the woman I mean talk
about Petty but then the thing is that
every time they brought up the Bureau of
Labor Statistics the censes the CDC he
made Sean Hannity made Gavin Nome the
liar that he is I mean the taxes in
California the people leaving California
and then telling people that you've
created jobs because you're allowing
them to return to the jobs that you lock
them out of
unconstitutionally during the lockdown
is a straight out lie so the bottom line
is here's a guy who destroyed the city
of San Francisco became the governor of
the state of California now he's destroy
the state of California wants to be
president of the United States and I
think people saw him for a petty slimy
guy
did Nome win on style or substance or
neither well good to see well and sing
here at table i' say a couple things um
I thought both of them did well last
night um I thought some of the facts as
it relates to Mr Dan santis estate he
was able to get some of those things out
uh around Co and taxes uh I thought that
Governor Nome was able to get a lot of
things out about his State I do think
some of the numbers are around people
that have moved there and jobs being
created I don't think we get the full
picture and I thought both of them tried
their hardest to share that Vision we
didn't get a real vision of of or should
say we didn't understand how that vision
would translate to them being president
I thought Shawn did a great job of
making sure this was about these states
giving giving both of these Governors an
opportunity whose States had been in the
spotlight rightly so during Co after Co
about how they've responded how they
what kind of resiliency their economy is
showing and their people are showing so
I thought that was thought that was
positive now to your question about the
style I I thought that Governor Nome
who's a good-look guy and and presents
well and presents it a strong way uh
found his probably found the better of
Governor DeSantis in some of those
exchanges because he for whatever reason
seemed to be I thought a little more
prepared where I thought Governor Des
santis was more prepared he countered
with substance at times and and many
times and I thought that uh in many ways
allowed the counter uh in the balance to
be struck but I thought the two most
telling and revealing and memorable
lines for me well we showed one of them
where we said neither of us will be the
nominee in 2024 and I think Sandra and I
might have reacted to that a bit and I
think Republicans have to I think
realize from on a national level this
issue of women's health and Reproductive
Rights and abortion as we uniquely and
succinctly call it this issue is not
going away uh and you've got I think
that if the national party is unable in
the Republican side is unable to get a
better answer than what governor Des
santis gave last night I think it's
going to be hard at least she gave an
answer sir well well so the the only
electoral L you're right and I'm not
going to quarrel with you on that but I
do know this the only thing I can point
to is what the voters are saying and
just three weeks ago and Kentucky and
Ohio uh two Republican states voters
said that abortion was a big issue for
them so overall I give them both B
pluses they're both patriotic they're
both passionate and neither will be the
nominee in you know Jesse I'm concerned
because I think Gavin Nome is a very
effective prolific easy sociopathic liar
and I think he does an excellent job of
lying I think the santis won the debate
because he had reality and facts on his
side but Newsome would have you believe
last night that the California economy
is booming that people are moving from
Florida to California that it was the
most open State during covid he would
have you believe a completely false
reality that I do think Dan santis was
capable of pushing back on but Nome does
it with such ease and I'm not concerned
with people that already like the santis
I'm not concerned with Trump voters I'm
not even concerned with Nome voters or
Biden voters I'm concerned with casual
casual news Watchers casual voters that
tune in and all they see is that slick
Authority I don't know if it's true or
not he's dice some stat it's impossible
to pars he was full of numbers and to
your point judge he was full of
moralizing as well how would you dare
demean LGBT community as you ban books
there's the LIE random stat 3,000 books
and then moralize about demeaning people
and the Casual viewer might just walk
away from that slick presentation going
hm that guy sounds like he knows what
he's talking about yeah that's why it's
a debate though and and disantis showed
up with facts and that was pretty easy
you can make the case that he won before
he even got on the stage uh when you
present facts like gas price is almost
five bucks in in California they're just
over $3 in Florida uh you look at the
economy in Florida much different
situation uh you've got people paying
$5,400 in per capita taxes over 10,000
in California you've got the deficit
soaring in California $31 billion
Florida's running a surplus of over 17
billion you've got this population
migration which was really easy for
someone like the santis to fall back on
I think it came up I I think we all
heard it multiple times come up um
44,000 people left Florida between 2021
and 2022 uh 700 sorry 750,000 left
California 450,000 went to Florida
Florida perhaps the the line of the
night was the story that hookline and
sinker uh disantis brought up that he
was talking to a gentleman who fled
California for Florida it happened to be
Newsome's father-in-law um the timing on
that was pretty spectacular who won the
night um voters will certainly decide um
the American public will decide I think
there were some really interesting
substantive moments and we all win for
this conversation happening in the first
place for this debate even happening
kudos to Shan Hannity great job I think
there was some really substantive
debates that happened up there and I
think people learned something about
about each person Governor yeah kudos to
Shawn and kudos to Harold Ford Jr who
said Gavin Nome was handsome and and I
respect that your bravery from coming
out and saying that thank you very much
are you trying to say something I'm not
I'm not you said it what are you doing
you said I love you I love you more hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling annalysis you will not get it
anywhere
else